data analyst versus data engineer versus
data scientist which one to choose
this is one of the most popular
questions asked by learners looking for
a career in data and analytics
i'm sure youtube would have come across
these job roles in the ever-growing data
science landscape
though they all deal with data these
jobs are not the same there are
significant differences between what a
data analyst data engineer and a data
scientist does
we will look at these job roles and the
differences in detail
first
let's look at some data analytics and
data science trends
the analytics and data science smart
data is thriving
data analytics data engineering and data
science are the key trends in today's
accelerating market
as per statista.com
global big data analytics market revenue
will grow at a cagr of 30 percent with
revenue reaching over 68 billion us
dollars by 2025.
according to technavio
the enterprise data management market is
expected to increase by
64.08 billion us dollars by 2025.
as per
marketsandmarkets.com the big data
market size is projected to grow
from 162.6 billion us dollars in 2021
to
273.4 billion u.s dollars in 2026.
now another report from research drive
says that the data science platform
market is estimated to reach
224.3 billion us dollars by 2026.
so with so much data available and
companies making huge investments to
drive business and sites the job
opportunities for data analysts data
engineers and data scientists are going
to increase in 2022 and over the coming
years
now
let's learn the major differences
between data analyst versus data
engineer versus data scientist
so
who are they
a data analyst analyzes and interprets
vast volumes of data in order to extract
meaningful information out of it
they find solutions to a business
problem and make critical business
decisions
the insights provided by data analysts
are important to companies that want to
understand the needs of their end
customers
now talking about
who a data engineer is
a data engineer on the other hand builds
infrastructure and scalable pipelines to
manage the flow of data and prepare it
for analysis
so basically they optimize the systems
that enable data analysts and data
scientists to perform their job
efficiently
data scientists are professionals who
analyze and visualize existing data and
use algorithms to build predictive
models for making future decisions
they also engage with business leaders
to understand their needs and present
complex findings
with that let's look at the primary
roles and responsibilities of
these three job roles
data analysts are responsible to collect
clean store and process data
they discover hidden patterns from data
by performing exploratory data analysis
and visualize data by creating charts
and graphs
acquiring data from primary and
secondary sources is one of their key
tasks
the build reports and dashboards and
also maintain databases
now talking about the roles and
responsibilities of a data engineer
a data engineer performs data
acquisition
the design build and test data as well
to develop and maintain data
architecture
data engineers are tasked with testing
integrating managing and optimizing data
from a variety of sources so they
integrate data into existing data
pipelines prepare data for modeling and
perform various etl operations
now talking about the roles and
responsibilities of a data scientist
so data scientists develop machine
learning models to identify trends in
data for making decisions
that develop hypothesis and use the
knowledge of statistics data
visualization and machine learning to
forecast the future for the business
data scientists visualize data and use
storytelling techniques and also write
programs to automate data collection and
processing
now move on to the skills possessed by
data analysts data engineers and data
scientists
to become a data analyst you need to
have good hands-on experience with
writing sql queries
you should have excellent microsoft
excel skills for analyzing data
data analysts are also good at
programming and they
need to know how to visualize data solve
business problems and possess domain
knowledge
data engineers should have a solid
understanding of sql mongodb and
programming
they need to have a good command of data
architecture scripting data warehousing
and etl
data engineers are also good at hadoop
based analytics
now talking about the skills for a data
scientist so a data scientist should
have experience with programming in
python and r
this would have a very good
understanding of mathematics and
statistics as well
data scientists need to possess
analytical thinking and data
visualization skills as well
machine learning deep learning and
decision making are other critical
skills every data scientist should have
now we look at the salaries of a data
scientist a data analyst as well as a
data engineer
so a data analyst in the united states
earns over seventy thousand dollars per
annum while in india a data analyst can
earn nearly seven lakh twenty five
thousand rupees per annum
a data engineer in the united states can
earn over hundred and twelve thousand
five hundred dollars
per year and in india you can earn over
nine lakh rupees per annum
we're talking about the salary of a data
scientist a data scientist in the united
states earns over 117 thousand dollars
per annum and in india a data scientist
can earn over 11 lakh rupees per annum
coming to the final section of this
video we look at the top companies
hiring for data analysts data engineers
and data scientists
so we have the
first company as google then we have
tesla
next we have the e-commerce giant amazon
the internet giant
facebook or the social media giant
facebook we have the tech giant oracle
we also have verizon and airbnb so these
are some of the top companies that hire
for the three roles
and that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on
data analyst versus data engineer versus
data scientists if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here